[Musik]
sebastian zaubert ein wundermittel der
lebensmittelindustrie selber milchpulver
im duell will sebastian beweisen dass
nicht einmal ein profi den unterschied
zu frischer milch schmeckt als
cremesuppe lecker schön cremige dessert
soße lecker auf der roten grütze
kartoffelpüree hier die schnelle
variante klassisch kommt der relativ
viel butter und sahne rein hier statt
butter und sahne steckt hier tatsächlich
etwas anderes drin magermilchpulver eine
beliebte zutat in vielen fertiggerichten
bei traditioneller herstellungsweise
werden bei diesen produkten sehr viel
tierische fette verwendet
die lebensmittelindustrie hat einen weg
gefunden diese zu sparen um
kostengünstiger zu produzieren und wie
das funktioniert das zeichen jetzt
butter sahne und vollmilch sorgen in
vielen gerichten für den typischen
geschmack und die cremigkeit
ausschlaggebend dabei ist das mischfett
mutter besteht fast nur aus fett in
sahne stecken gut 30 prozent
und in vollmilch rund 3,5 prozent
dabei gilt je mehr milchfett desto
teurer ist das lebensmittel
doch es gibt noch ein weiteres produkt
morger milch mit 0,5 prozent fällt
vergleichsweise geschmacklos aber mit
abstand am billigsten und daher bei der
industrie besonders beliebt vor allem
als zutat von fertigprodukten sorgt
mager milch für klingende kassen
wie aus der milch das begehrte pulver
gewonnen wird das will und pflege mit
dieser konstruktion demonstrieren
meine sprüht trocknungsanlage sieht sehr
kompliziert aus ist aber kinderleicht
reist oft ein kessel ein hochleistungs
zyklon eine ganz normale pumpe und einen
industriestaubsauger sorgen dafür dass
ich hier gleich mister magic des
milchpulvers werde milchpulver wird mit
der sogenannten sprühtrocknung
hergestellt legis anlage veranschaulicht
was in der industrie im großen maßstab
abläuft die maschine steht unter strom
jetzt kann ich mit dem sprühtrocknung
prozessbeginn und muss nur noch die
fettfreie mich in die kleine flasche
füllen
sebastian nägel nimmt dazu
handelsübliche mager milch die soll
gleich durch den schlauch in den kessel
gepumpt werden
jetzt bin ich bereit muss nur noch auf
das rote knöpfchendrücken sprühtrocknung
marsch
als erstes startet der heißluft von am
oberen ende der anlage der heizt in
sekundenschnelle luft auf und leitet sie
in den kessel
dann saugt sebastian mit hilfe einer
pumpe die mager milch aus der flasche
und leitet sie so richtung kessel eine
sogenannte hochdruck düse am eingang des
kessels zerstäubt die flüssige milch in
winzig kleine partikel durch die enorme
hitze im kessel verdampft der
wasseranteil in der magermilch
übrigbleiben milchzucker milcheiweiß und
ein bisschen rest fällt die teilchen
werden vom staubsauger aus dem kessel
gesaugt und landen schließlich als
fertiges magermilchpulver in der tonne
hier ist es magermilchpulver aus sieben
litern milch wird ein kilo
magermilchpulver die vorteile für die
industrie sind enorm das trockene pulver
ist lange ungekühlt haltbar
es lässt sich günstig transportieren und
man kann damit ordentlich tricksen
[Musik]
was das für uns verbraucher heißt will
sebastian lege demonstrieren
dazu fährt der produktentwickler nach
neuss bei düsseldorf hier in der
brasserie koch tobias havenstein
traditionell französisch das heißt in
seine gerichte kommt kein
magermilchpulver sondern ganz klassisch
butter sahne und vollmilch die küche in
der küche erwarten sebastian bereits
zwei gerichte schon ein bisschen was
vorbereitet
ja wir gucken ja heute eine tomatensuppe
kartoffelpüree alles mit butter und
sahne bei uns sebastian nimmt eine
kostprobe zuerst die tomaten cremesuppe
wo es aber schön cremig meinem freund
für den gast nur das beste
also da machen wir auf den liter auf den
liter tomaten cremesuppe machen wir 70
80 gramm butter und 100 milliliter sahne
damit besteht die suppe zu rund 18
prozent aus fett reichen milchprodukten
ähnlich auch beim kartoffelpüree mit
viel butter und milch kartoffeln hat
welche zutaten kartoffeln butter milch
salz pfeffer muskat auf ein kilo
kartoffelpüree machen wir haben wir 300
gramm butter schon die franzosen die
machen das ja machen dass er mit der
kartoffel halb und halb sagen ja auch
immer die würdigung mehr butter ganz
schön teuer denn wir erinnern uns im
handel kostet ein kilo butter um die
sechs euro ein liter sahne im
durchschnitt 3 euro 30 hersteller
ersetzen das teure butter oder milch
fett deshalb lieber durch günstige
pflanzenfette rapsöl gibt es schon ab 99
cent pro liter palmfett ab 1 eur 49 aber
fällt diese lobby nicht auf sebastian
koch beide gerichte nach ersetzt dabei
teuer durch billig und nutzt die
geheimwaffe der industrie
magermilchpulver
zuerst die suppe stadtbahnen im
pflegefall macht aufs kilo gerechnet 55
prozent ersparnis weiß wenn jetzt erst
mal so richtig schönen palmfett glanz
kredit auf der oberfläche weiß wie gut
die dann schmeckt werde ich mich gleich
überzeugen lassen dass palmfett ist
cremig doch der typische milch geschmack
und die farbe der saane fehlen
jetzt kommt das magermilchpulver ins
spiel ein kleiner löffel reicht optisch
kommt lege damit dem original des kochs
schon sehr nahe doch hält die billig
version auch dem gaumen check stand
granate würde ich sagen dafür dass keine
butter keine analyse der fiese marga
milch trinkt fällt selbst den profi kaum
auf beim kartoffelpüree selbst läge
sogar noch eins drauf auch hier nimmt er
das billigste pflanzenfett und spart
sich so ganze 80 prozent der kosten für
gute butter und vollmilch und wieder
kassiert magermilchpulver den schwindel
aufgelöst in heißen kartoffel wasser
was sagt der koch zum billig püree
[Musik]
lecker
also ohne butter ohne sahne milch aber
schon sehr cremig auch ne tiptop also
hier bin ich noch überzeugt wie bei der
tomaten sollte ganz ehrlich weil hier
schmeckst du wirklich die butter
schmelzen
ich könnte jetzt links rechts eins zu
eins soll ich hier von meiner katze mir
das immer die sonne
experiment geglückt die täuschung nahezu
perfekt selbst für den profi
[Musik]
in vielen gerichten sparen sich die
hersteller butter sahne oder vollmilch
auch dort wo wir sie traditionell
erwarten in diesem fertig köris steckt
statt vollmilch und butter oder milch
und ein feld in cremesuppen wird seine
ebenfalls durch magermilchpulver und
pflanzenfett ersetzt
und statt teurer butter enthalten diese
saucen ebenfalls nur eine mager
milchflaschen fact mixtur auf den ersten
blick ist der trick nicht erkennbar
im gegenteil butter und milch locken
auch so mancher verpackung ein blick auf
die zutatenliste schafft klarheit
der verbraucher sollte sich von so einem
vollen milchglas nicht blenden lassen es
sieht natürlich aus als wäre jetzt ganz
frische milch in diesem produkt aber in
diesen technologisch verarbeiteten
produkten ist es in der regel nicht
enthalten
rechtlich ist es wahrscheinlich möglich
das so zu machen denn man sieht diese
produkte und es ist immer eine sehr sehr
schwierige einzelfall entscheidung bei
lebensmitteln ist es jetzt täuschend
oder nicht und es ist natürlich milch
enthalten
von daher dürfen die hersteller das
machen so engmaschig deutsche gesetze
auch sind eine gesunde skepsis gegenüber
dem was die ketten so alles suggerieren
die sollten wir kunden uns bewahren
greift ihr manchmal zum fertigprodukt
oder macht der kartoffelbrei lieber
selber sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips